hey there boyle how was your weekend
well
actually i got a little sick oh really
i'm sorry to hear that man
yeah bullets over broadway was on tv i
came down with a big old diane
weast infection
like yeast guys guys guys we missed
scully's birthday and it was a big one
i know i panicked and said i had to go
to the vet because my puppy cat got sick
i said i had to take my mom to get birth
control pills this stupid limp is
slowing me down
charles can you give you a piggy that
hey jump on it i'll give you a piggy
nypd open up all right i'm gonna break
down the door no
let me do it charles that's never gone
well yes but i've been practicing all
right fine you get one try thank you
police hands in the air i did it yes ah
oil that's the bad guy yup yup
the only way to make things right is to
do the worst most awful thing imaginable
dip your penis in vinegar what no why
would you say that
in sunday school they told us the
babylonians did that to their enemies
i've been terrified ever since you're
standing look out we
in the front door smoking a cigarette
check it ash okay so
i am what smoking you doing ah
jacques rolls his own cigarettes a habit
he picked up from a prostitute marseille
but that is not all he picked up why do
all your characters get stds because
they're living
life i'm telling you once they get their
strong fingers
in your toe gaps it's just
[Music]
i show up grind a bunch of gnarly rails
i'm talking real fluffy ones
radical i bet you're an awesome fluffer
yeah i bet you fluffed those other
riders right out of their biker shorts
charles i can picture you as a teenager
fluffing all of new york city
cheryl stop talking fluffing has a
different meaning we're gonna drive
around in the coolest undercover car on
the impound lot
herbie from herbie fully loaded but no
it's not the best case ever without some
toys
oh yeah toys for boys
i don't know if i like that adult toys
still sounds wrong male toys you know
what let's just not call them toys
that's my fault i started it you got it
we'll just call them playthings we will
not let's do this
for you and you
and you what are these these madame
are stds
what are you talking about buddy stds
save the dates
for vivian on my wedding ah yes hey just
out of curiosity how many people have
you given stds to
lots like a hundred
[Laughter]
what's going on uh oh okay i get it std
has another meaning
you're gross no one else is gonna think
that everyone is going to think that but
it's sweet that your mind didn't go
there
thank you it is kind of sweet will your
first dance be too you give me fever
will you be serving crabs at the
reception do you have herpes boyle why
don't you show donger what a fax machine
is
okay okay imagine a letter
had unprotected sex with a phone i'm
working on a thing where
when i'm out of ammo i release my mag
and dropkick gets straight into
someone's throat
oh my buttholes
okay i know you have two bullet wounds
in your butt but you got to stop calling
them your buttholes detective boyle i
just wanted to say congratulations
your medal was well deserved thank you
sir your breath is terrible
me and my main man boyle are about to
solve a case isn't that right charles oh
you know we will
we'll call ourselves the night boys kind
of sounds like a male escort service the
midnight men even worse
the dark stallions looks like we're
going with the night boys
all right let's go over our covers one
more time we are small-time operators
that just moved here from miami we
piloted go fast boats moving contraband
to cuba well we slept with the same
prostitute
no and she said you were the best she
ever had maybe and i should watch you to
learn
back to no let's just not talk about our
sex lives well we're actually looking
for some work right now we just
got into town for miami where we didn't
sleep with the same prostitute
yes the engaged life is amazing
especially sexually well i don't want to
pry you're not prying i want you to know
this
no okay be kind i don't have a model's
body like you
come on show what you got
fred astaire gene kelly liberace diane
keaton
roger that
okay charles you're not scottish
yeah get back in there braveheart summer
linen suit
casual but classic actually not bad
one question can you see my underwear ah
thong
why are you wearing a thong it's why
something borrowed
get back in there i have spectacular
taste in men
you would love nadia his name is nadia
oh
all of a sudden nadia is not a cool name
you are impossible
it's halloween i'm surprised you didn't
put on a costume
i was going to sir but then i decided
screw that jazz
well i'm the only one who ever dresses
up no one ever gets my costume and they
make fun of me
so i'm done these people don't deserve
my dress-up gifts
yes charles seriously no costume
what the hell charles where's your
halloween spirit but
you guys always make fun of me i have
never once
insulted you in my life especially
vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no
[Music]
bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but uh but
yeah what are you supposed to be a sassy
car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop tart i
am not you know who i am squad that's
enough
you're making boyle for batman purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater no
and now it's time to send in our cute
little secret weapon
i'm ready captain i love the nickname no
charles not you
i was talking about cheddar oh right
obviously
over the past month i've had him trained
to retrieve plaques and now boy
it's time to make daddy proud yes sir i
could not have been more clearly talking
to the dog
oh hey donut holes don't mind if i do
oh fish fish donuts boyle what is wrong
with you
it's takoyaki i'm drowning my sorrows in
octopus balls what are you doing
she's walking away i got nervous she
eats octopus balls angie slips on the
floor
she's the perfect woman you guys were
hitting it off i half expected to see
you sitting in her lap by now
she is amazing her palette is wide and
deep
gross and at one point when she wasn't
looking i snuck a whiff of her hair of
course you did
i'm donald hoberman's sights i wear
glasses
is that all you got sorry i spent the
cab right here imagining me and
genevieve kissing not too late to ditch
amy and team up with this
pussycat burglar please boyle your only
value was you had a doppelganger which
no longer matters since bill died in
that accident
it can still be useful without bill no
hole's too tight for these tiny tips
for stealing stuff first of all throw up
second of all how'd you get back here so
fat if you get a box wet enough it's
very easy to bust out of it no one asked
any follow-ups i really thought i was
gonna get genevieve out of prison
then we'd cover ourselves in paint and
make love for 25 hours
one more hour than her and nick boyle
you would hate that your little
hummingbird heart would explode
i will not be using a loophole peralta
as always i'll be using the main hole or
no hole
i choose no holes you just said whole
way too much sir and that's coming from
charles yes that's concerning
you